markiplier a wall oh god I can't even
see what's happening oh my goodness I
didn't find these Rick no Caspi 1405 you
are like the best happy wheels level
maker ever by far what else you got for
me game so far I've gotten all the
deaths what else yeah blue machete huh
well it seems to be a common occurrence
that most of my playthroughs now have a
lot of
slam okay Wow fails you fat
oh god no Jesus Christ save the baby why
do I have that didn't help it all my
family oh crap I can feel it another
slam dunk huh
well [ __ ] yeah excuse you pardon me
ma'am
well this guy looks tough over here
better take him son okay oh oh wait a
minute I was ready to go and the game
wasn't ready for me so oh there we go
oh whoa all right then apparently oh oh
ok it was a trick secret yay washing
fall Oh story time
banana murder oh well Santa's always mad
so
good throw by cell okay all right wine
I'm gonna Cuddy something doesn't feel
right
toughen to me
oh you guess again I win wait a minute
do I win that sassy sue ain't gonna let
you get the best of me hoop bend our
knees ooh
and then we Bend our knees again oh yeah
I got the Technic hey check it where am
I going
what uh control while falling I made it
on the hard mode how am i oh God
ninja toner what oh I got a bad feeling
about this
i watch you what are you a pervert
oh those are good yeah whoa whoa whoa
kitties you're gonna get caught on here
oh do I was I stabbed in the butt or do
I really have to go to the bathroom I
should probably not be doing this right
now
oh that did not feel good whatever that
van
it said markiplier cannot win this is my
first attempt at the level just
markiplier
made it okay you win I can't win it
either but I don't think anybody out
there could that's a challenge everybody
there's the level
markiplier saves him instead of having
to kill no oh my god did you save him oh
no mark has been shrunk by the
mannequins and stuck to a Segway I guess
you must help him traverses kitchen but
who knows what evils could be lying in
wait ahead okay an Evo vampire quick get
over the stuff what does that mean thank
you from Argentina for making me this
markiplier level Wow
alright nothing's gonna beat stop
stopping for the old man okay then
there's me sir I need to drop my live
son off at school no no my bottle run
thank you Wow and also Al oh boy it's
another tiny box Tim kill the wall Tim
no that radioactive goof was not okay or
you could just hug them and not kill any
of them that's also an option oh that
guy deserved it though but everyone else
you're the best Tim you're just
delightful
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you want to see
more happy wheels right now check the
description or click the annotation for
the full happy wheels playlist and if
you want to see more happy wheels in the
future please click the like button to
let me know thanks again everyone and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye